bubba wallace good morning to you and
congratulations
take us back take us back
we're all good we're all good but very
excited for you because i will never be
drenched in champagne i wonder what that
feels like for you take us back to that
moment
yeah it's uh it's sticky it's it's nasty
at the end of the day but it's all worth
it that's the the price of winning and
uh just uh thank you for the opportunity
proud of my team
we're uh we're working hard and we've
been working hard all year to get to
that moment and finally paid off for us
hey bubba do you know who desiree
wallace is
i do it's my lovely mother
that's your lovely mom so i called her
last night bubba to ask her about that
moment for you and she said she knew all
along that this would happen it was a
mat it wasn't a matter of of if it was a
matter of when and she said it always
happens in god's time and that she said
this was a boost that everybody needed
when it started looking like it was
going to rain she said she called
friends and said everybody pray for rain
everybody pray for rain because this is
bubba's moment
is she right exactly right yeah she's
right uh we had a good feeling going
into it amanda my fiance and i um
we caught it on friday i believe you
know we just had a good feeling it
reminded me of the feeling that i had
back in 2013
when i won my first truck race um just
knew we were gonna win this race and um
moments throughout the race there was
times where i'm like man this isn't the
feeling that i had but it came down at
the right time so you never question it
you always stick true to it and uh it
works out
yeah now bubba i've always said as a
former athlete we stand on the shoulders
of giants wendell scott was the first
black driver to win a nascar cup race
but he didn't actually receive his
trophy when you won did you feel like
you were carrying on the legacy of
wendell
yeah no doubt i mean each and every race
we're doing that and being able to
become really close with the windows
scott family and hear all the stories
and just you know be motivated by that
is super special to me i was able to
talk to franklin after the race and um
you know that was a cool moment there
being a daytona when they received the
trophy um just just a lot of history a
lot of nostalgia you know just a lot of
proud moments from everybody in our camp
you know our team really is passionate
about moving diversity ahead and and so
to continue to carry on that flame that
that he had lit is um is super special
just proud of everybody i mean from
from everybody's front office everybody
was working hard back in the shop
everybody at the shop was watching the
race because we raced on monday so it
was a huge team win you know big win for
us in uh mcdonald's their first win
since uh 94. uh so just proud of all our
wow
wow maybe you want a mcdonald's french
fry you know they have the best fast
that's real fries just saying and the
ice cream cones are pretty solid as well
i will endorse those uh let's talk about
that team though uh bubba a co-owner of
your team is uh nba great michael jordan
a guy who's known to be pretty
competitive also a guy not afraid to cry
in public so you take those two things
together i'm curious what was his
reaction to your win and what did he say
to you about it oh he was just so pumped
uh he left me a voicemail just saying
congrats and how proud he was of us and
the team um but we just got to keep
going you know uh
don't uh don't let up don't get
complacent we still got a
few races left to end off the season and
a lot to look forward to the next season
but i think you know for for him and
denny you know just everybody coming
together all of our partners uh in
november
um toyota doordash mcdonald's dr pepper
root colombia you know they all came
about in such a short amount of time to
make this deal possible for us so um you
know we appreciate them so much so it
was nice to get everybody in victory
lane everybody that pushes me from from
the team side to the family side but you
know mj was pumped his camp was pumped
but we got to keep going
your mom was pumped too she said she
never doubted you ever ever ever did you
ever doubt yourself
uh at times i think that's the
competitive side that it continues to
make us stronger and push harder you
know when you when you start to doubt
yourself it's tough it's a slippery
slope um but i've doubted myself once
twice
take that nascar by through the
drive-through at mcdonald's see if they
serve you yeah no doubt about it man
looking for that bubba shake all done
all doubts are gone bubba wallace
congratulations milkshake machine is
that bubba thank you i know you had a
birthday on friday happy birthday
celebrate man because you deserve it
thank you for joining us